大家好,我是Jim,這裡是AI Notebook。
這一集是一個新系列,演講訪談系列的第一集。
主角是Alexander Wong,他19歲創辦Scale AI,現在在Meta帶領超級智慧實驗室。
今年夏天,他回到YC的創業回校,對著臺下一群18-20歲的年輕人說了一句很大的話。
他說,現在可能是一個文明只會遇到一次的機會。
這一集只問一個問題,這句話是真的嗎?
如果是真的,機會到底在哪裡?跟我們一般人又有什麼關係?
我先把答案放在前面。
他的意思是AI的智慧正在變成按一下就拿得到的東西
當智慧不再稀少
最缺的就變成知道要往哪裡走的人
這句話我覺得有一半站得住
另一半要打折
因為說這句話的人
正好在全世界花最多錢追趕AI的公司之一
負責這整件事
我們分三步走
先看他年輕的時候怎麼看見別人沒看見的東西
再看他說的機會到底長什麼樣子
最後把他的身份放回來
看看這句話要打幾折
先從2016年一個19歲的大學生開始
先認識臺上的兩個人
主持人叫Gary Tan
他是Y Combinator的執行長
Y Combinator大家簡稱YC
是矽谷很有名的創業加速器
他做的事情很簡單
投一小筆錢給
剛起步的團隊
再陪他們走三個月
把產品做出來
Startup School
是YC辦的創業學校
臺下做的
大多是想創業的學生
跟年輕工程師
坐在Gary對面的
就是Alexander Wang
2016年夏天
他19歲
帶著一個點子進了YC
那家公司後來叫Scale AI
9年後
2025年6月
Meta宣佈投資Scale AI
143億美元
買下將近一半的股份
同時把汪本人請進Meta
他的頭銜是首席AI長
帶領一個新成立的部門
叫Meta Super Intelligence Labs
中文是Meta
超級智慧實驗室
超級智慧的意思是
在幾乎所有事情上
都比人更強的AI
所以這場對談有點特別
臺下作者的
很像十年前的他
Gary一開始就問
你18歲的時候在想什麼
他的回答很老實
他在新墨西哥州的
Los Alamos長大
從小參加數學跟城市競賽
知道自己想做大事
可是不知道怎麼做
高中畢業以後
他先去矽谷的問答網站
Cora工作了一年
再去讀MIT
他說這兩段經驗
各給了他一樣東西
在公司裡他看到一群人
實際上怎麼做決定
怎麼把一個東西一改再改
在MIT
他第一次自己動手訓練AI模型
讀了一年
他就申請了YC
不過他進YC時代的點子並不是scale
他們原本想做一個AI助理
幫人處理看病這件事
做了一兩個月
YC的合夥人Jarrett Friedman
把他們拉到一邊說
這個方向我不確定會有結果
忘說那正是他們需要聽到的話
今天回頭看
他覺得那個點子本身沒有錯
現在真的有人在做
用AI幫人看病的工具
錯的是時間點
2016年的技術還做不到
所以他們回到一張白紙
重新想機會到底在哪裡
答案
藏在他在MIT訓練模型的時候
遇到的一個麻煩力
訓練一個AI模型
他說需要三樣東西
這裡我用一間廚房來比喻
這一集會一直回來用它
第一樣是算力
也就是電腦的計算能力
它像廚房裡的爐子
第二樣是程式碼
告訴電腦一步一步怎麼學
它像食譜
第三樣是資料
模型
要從大量的例子裡學到
它像食材
2016年前兩樣都很好拿
爐子可以跟雲端公司租
它當時用的是Google的雲端賬號
按一下就有
食譜網路上也找得到
Google前不久才公開了一套訓練模型的工具
叫Tension Flow
可是食材不一樣
你想教模型認出馬路上的車
就得先有一大堆照片
每一張都有人仔細框出
車在哪裡
行人在哪裡
這種整理好
標好答案的資料
沒有地方可以按一下就買到
他覺得這件事太明顯了
未來一定會有一個按鈕按下去就拿到資料
這一段聽他自己怎麼說
所以Scale做的事
就是當時才供應商
他找來大量的人
配上好用的工具
把照片
影片
文字
一筆一筆標好答案
再賣給要訓練模型的公司
這個工作叫資料標準
第一批大客戶是做自動駕駛的公司
因為在那個年代
最需要看懂馬路畫面的
就是自動駕駛的車
聽起來很合理
可是在那幾年
這個生意一點都不吸引人
我跟你說
公司的營收明明長得很好
每次出去募資
創業投資公司還是一臉懷疑
他們會問
這種生意做得久嗎
撐得住嗎
這段我第一次聽
覺得有點意外
一家數字很好看的公司
為什麼還是說服不了人
他後來想通了原因
聽他自己講
你知道
they'd be like
他們會說
does it have longevity
is this durable
and it was really weird to me
對我來說很奇怪
so I guess they didn't really get it
這件事後來整個翻了過來
大型預言模型紅了以後
資料變成大家搶著要的東西
他說當年不看好 scale 的同一批投資人
現在在寫文章講資料有多重要
Gary 接著問
這種事情你是怎麼撐過來的
Wong的回答
是這場對談裡他最常回來講的一個詞
conviction
中文可以翻成信念或是篤定
他說的篤定
不只是自信心很強
他的意思是
你相信一件事
身邊幾乎沒有人同意你
你還是照著它做
他給的證據是
回頭看世界上最成功的那些公司
創辦的時候
他們的核心想法都還沒有流行
他們要在沒有人注意的地方
默默做很多年
等到大家都同意的那一天
聽聽他怎麼說
所有世界上最有成績的企業
他們在一段時間之前
他後面還補了一句
如果你太跟著人群走
你會非常困惑
最後哪裡都到不了
所以每個人都要有自己的指南針
自己判斷未來會長什麼樣子
這個指南針
影片
最後他還會再講一次
第一部分走到這裡
我們整理一下
王在2016年看見的機會
有三個特點
他不在新聞頭條上
他在他自己動手訓練模型
卡住的那個地方
他很無聊
無聊到投資人看不懂
而且他得一直做下去
做到世界追上來
用廚房來說
當時爐子跟食譜都按一下就有
缺的是食材
他就去當了食材供應商
這一部分只要記住一句
機會常常長在缺的那一樣東西上
那到了2026年
廚房裡缺的又是什麼
Gary問了一個很直接的問題
現在創業的人手上有AI可以用
跟你當年比起來會不會快很多
汪先講了一個判斷
他說現在卡住的
不是AI模型進步的夠不夠快
卡住的是這些已經存在的技術
要怎麼走進世界的每個角落
這件事有一個名字
叫技術擴散
他的意思是
一項新技術從實驗室出發
一路走進公司學校醫院政府
最後變成大家每天在用的東西
說穿了
模型就算從今天起不再進步
大部分的公司跟政府
也還沒學會怎麼好好用它
光是追上現在的模型
就有很多事情要做
然後他講了這場對談最有名的一句話
聽他自己說
和歷史上的經濟
和世界的運作
以及我們周圍的一切
所以我認為
這將會成為
一個最驚人的
可能是一個
在一個文明時代的機會
去成為夢想者
去擁有夢想
一個文明只會遇到一次
這句話很大
我們先看他給的理由
他說
十年前他創辦SCALE的時候
創業向大衛對抗哥里亞
這是聖經裡的故事
牧羊少年大衛拿著一顆石頭
打倒了全副武裝的巨人哥利亞
小公司資源少
只能找一個很巧妙的角度
從縫隙裡鑽進市場
可是現在
他說情況變了
關鍵是AI代理程式
代理程式英文叫agent
他是為自己一步一步
把事情做完的AI程式
給他一個目標
他會自己查資料
寫程式
檢查結果再修改
不用你每一步都盯著他
如果一個小團隊
背後有一大群這樣的代理程式
在幫忙
他就不再是那個拿石頭的少年
聽他怎麼形容
GIGA巨人
這個畫面很好記
可是要讓小團隊
變成GIGA巨人
有一個前提
這些代理程式要用得起
代理程式做一件事
背後要讓模型跑很多很多次
他查一次資料
就要讀一大段文字
他改一次程式又要再想一遍
模型越貴帳單就越腫
這就是Gary接下來講的事
他說他自己用Meta的新模型Musepark跑代理程式
覺得效果跟Anthropic的旗艦模型Opus差不多
價錢卻便宜八倍
這裡先記住
八倍是主持人跟Meta這一方的說法
第三部分我們會回來核對
哇 順著這句話
講了Meta的立場
是很重要的 讓所有人都能夠使用這個技術
去建造他們想要建造的東西
2012年Google的研究團隊
讓模型看了大量從YouTube影片
截出來的畫面
他自己學會了認出貓臉
當時是大新聞
而今天他說
我們在跟一個像數位神明的東西講話
數位神明是他的用詞
不是我的
當廚師不在其掃
廚房裡最缺的又是什麼
他的答案是
決定要煮什麼菜的人
聽他怎麼說
isn't gonna be intelligence or agency
我真的覺得
他說的願景不是寫在牆上的口號
他問的是很具體的事
5年到10年以後
你希望世界的哪一個地方
跟今天不一樣
你有沒有那股勁
願意穿過一路上所有麻煩的事
把它做出來
Gary請他再講具體一點
現在最大的機會在哪裡
Wong的答案是
讓代理城市去跑回饋循環
回饋循環的意思是
做一件事看結果
根據結果調整再做一次
他說一家公司
其實就是一個大的回饋循環
找到客戶 讓客戶更滿意 客戶花更多錢
同時再請更多人去找更多客戶
過去這個循環的每一個環節
都是人在推
如果你能給代理程式一個清楚的分數
讓他一直去追 他都在Meta內部看過
一群代理程式做出來的成果
比100個工程師的團隊還多
這是他的說法 外界沒有辦法驗證
那這些代理程式是怎麼跑起來的
答案頻繁到臺下都笑了
I think it's always funny
how mundane everything is
once you really dig into it
技能檔案
是寫給代理程式看的工作說明
Markdown是一種很簡單的
純文字格式
Chrome Drop
則像電腦裡的鬧鐘
時間一到
就自動把一件工作跑一次
把這些很平凡的零件接起來
就是他說的機會
第二部分整理一下
亡的
推理是這樣的
模型已經夠強
卡住的是擴散
代理程式讓小團隊
有機會跟大公司正面對抗
前提是模型夠便宜
而當智慧本身越來越便宜
最稀少的就變成願景跟那股勁
用廚房來說
2016年缺食材
今天連廚師都快要誰叫誰到
缺的是決定菜單的人
這一部分記住一句
智慧變便宜以後
最值錢的是方向
可是這整段話是誰說的
現在把說話的人放回來
汪不是旁觀的評論家
他是Meta的首席AI長
Meta正在用很大的力氣
追趕OpenAI
Anthropic跟Google
他自己在臺上講得很直接
Meta上一代的模型
Lama4
2025年4月推出
他說他不在Meta需要的那條軌道上
所以他進去以後
幾乎是從零開始
重蓋一間前沿實驗室
前沿實驗室指的是
做最強那一季模型的團隊
他說
最重要的是人才密度
厲害的人越多
越厲害的人就越想加入
他會自己越滾越大
這句話背後
是2025年夏天
祖克柏親自出面挖角
開出的條件
在紐約時報跟華爾街日報上都變成了新聞
不到一年2026年4月
實驗室推出第一個模型
Muse Spark
他的評價怎麼樣
同一年6月
在彭博的科技大會上
忘了自己說
這個模型還不在最前面那一集
到了這場對談
主持人說他跟OPOS差不多
這兩句話不一定矛盾
中間Muse Spark更新了一個版本
可是你會發現
同一個模型在不同的臺上
講法不太一樣
再來核對那個8倍
我們要把兩家公開的價目表放在一起看
在這場對談的時候
Meta的Muse Spark跟Anthropic
當時的OPOS比
同樣的用量輸入大約便宜4倍
輸出大約便宜6倍
所以照單價算
是4到6倍不是8倍
8倍要成立
還得把每個任務
實際用掉多少量也算進去
那是Meta這一方的策法
我們沒辦法自己驗證
便宜很多是真的
8倍要打一點折
另一件要放在一起看的是
是錢從哪裡來
旺說大衛對抗哥利亞的時代過去了
現在是巨人對巨人
可是Meta自己就是巨人
他在2026年7月的財報裡說
今年光是蓋資料中心買制服器這些設備
就要花1300億到1450億美元
這種錢叫資本支出
同一年5月Meta開始裁掉大約一成的員工
把模型價錢壓低
讓全世界的開發者都來用它
本來就是Meta追趕對手的辦法
這不代表他說的是假話
只是同一句話
也是一句很好的商業宣傳
這場對談公開到現在
兩個多月過去了
他在臺上預告了幾件事
我們可以一件一件對
他說Meta
很快會推出自己的Harness
Harness原本是馬具的意思
在這裡指的是把模型包起來
讓他能在你的電腦上讀檔案
寫程式
自己動手做事的那一層工具
8月5日
Meta推出了Muse Code
就是這樣一個寫程式的代理工具
他說Meta也在做開放的模型
8月10日
Meta公開了一個叫MuseGlimmer的模型
而且是開放權重
開放權重的意思是
模型本體放在網絡上
任何人都可以下載到自己的電腦上跑
不過它是比較小的版本
MuseBug本身並沒有公開
它說
每個人都有自己的個人超級智慧
9月8日
Meta推出個人代理程式
名字就叫Muse
可以幫你處理比較長的任務
接下來的發展
正好碰到它自己講的那個瓶頸
9月404 Media報導
Muse幫你打電話給店家了
功能在內部測試的階段
有一部分電話其實是真人客服打的
Meta說
內部測試本來就是開發的一部分
另外據GeekWire報導
Amazon也擋下了Muse
不讓他在Amazon的購物網站上幫人買東西
技術做出來了
別人願不願意讓他進門
大家信不信得過他
這就是他說的擴散
這一步
往往比做出模型還要慢
對談的最後
Gary問了一個很溫柔的問題
如果可以寄一封電報給18歲的自己
你會寫什麼
這個問題其實是替臺下問的
臺下那些18到20歲的人
就是當年的他
在聽他的答案之前
我們先記得這一路看到的兩件事
他在2016年看見的機會
是從自己動手卡住的地方長出來的
而他今天說的機會
是從一家正在花大錢的公司裡講出來的
帶著這兩件事聽他的第一句話
and people telling you shit
and like
it'll be very confusing
and it'll be very hard
這句話很動人
也有道理
可是我想替他補一個條件
篤定這件事
有一個很難看見的問題
叫倖存者偏差
他的意思是
你只看得到撐過來的人
而且一樣篤定
一樣在沒有人注意的地方
做了很多年
最後還是失敗的人
不會被請上臺演講
所以篤定
是成功的人常常有的東西
但不是有了他就會成功
汪自己的故事裡
其實藏著另一個條件
他對資料的篤定
不是憑空來的
是他在MIT自己訓練模型
平手卡在那裡才得到了
指南針要準
前提是你真的走過那一片地方
他的第二個建議
就比較能拿來檢查
他說要去找世界上那一條
曲線最陡又走得最久的指數成長
聽他怎麼說
在那時候是正確的投資方式
現在是AI進步
但未來將會有更多這種狹窄的曲線
默爾定律說的是
晶片上能放的電晶體
大約每兩年翻一倍
這條曲線撐了幾十年
帶出了個人電腦
也帶出了手機
汪認為
現在的那一條
是AI的進步
而且這種曲線的起點常常很無聊
就像當年只會認貓的模型
那對不打算創業的一般人呢
這場對談裡
有一段我覺得最實在
Gary提到
有些學生開始擔心
現在還要不要讀資訊工程
汪的回答是
有系統嚴謹的想事情
還是非常重要
他說
以前創業的人要寫程式
在學怎麼管理一群人
現在變成要學
怎麼指揮代理程式
接下來
是怎麼讓一大群代理程式
好好合作
工具一直在換
可是把一件事分成步驟
安排誰先誰後
檢查哪裡出錯
這種能力不會過時
所以如果他說的對
智慧會變得到處都是
那你手上最值錢的
是兩樣東西
一樣是你親手做過
知道哪裡會卡住的經驗
另一樣是
你清楚自己
想把世界的哪一個地方
變得更好
我們回到開場那個問題
一個正在替Meta追趕AI的人說
現在是一個文明只會遇到一次的機會
這句話站得住的那一半是
智慧正在變得便宜
到處都拿得到
2016年他看見廚房裡缺的是食材
1026年他看見缺的是知道要煮什麼的人
要打折的那一半是說這句話的人
也正需要全世界的開發者都來用他的模型
八倍要打一點折
代理城市要走進別人的家門
也比做出來慢得多
所以機會可能是真的
只是他不會自己落到你身上
他比較可能落在親手做過
又清楚自己要往哪裡走的人身上
這是演講訪談系列的第一集
之後我們會繼續挑重要的演講跟訪談
把講者的原生跟背景放在一起看
最後問你一個問題
如果智慧真的變得像按一個按鈕那麼容易
你最想用它
把生活裡的哪一件事變得不一樣
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見